arbic hablen packs roughing you up mob
ones mob and your courage well look no
further because this video will show you
the best way to blend in and have the
upper hand over those stupid butt heads
if your hunger for breath of the wild
tips ain't satisfied do check out our
other guides and sub for plenty of more
upcoming zelda features where to begin
well you're going to want to find kilt
in the monster salesman if you haven't
found him yet he's here on a small
island left of school lake head there at
night and you will see his colorful
hot-air balloon if you got the time you
can hit a pause at a college stable and
check off the side quest associate with
kill ttan once you talk with kill 10
he'll now appear between 8 p.m. and 4
a.m. around all main villages and towns
hit him up and he'll sell you some
pretty nifty gear such as monster masks
the catch is that you'll need to convert
monster parts into his own currency
called Mons the more rare the monster
part the more Mons he'll give you so now
you're grinding for monster parts
obviously you can grind for buck oblems
but you may want to consider this grind
on the dragon dinner all head to Hebrew
tower east of hyrule castle hop down
onto the edge of the canyon pull out
some wood and spark it sleep till
morning and to your left
BAM you should see dinner all the fire
dragon if you don't just keep trying
paraglide over it shoot its horns and a
horn chard should drop these are worth
300 rubies but also 150 Mons the dragon
will only drop one item per encounter so
just rinse and repeat that method so you
got Mon now what monster extract is
great for beefing up elixirs if that's
your thing he also sells them up or the
spring-loaded hammer which is alright it
essentially launches monsters pretty far
but that's only on the fourth hit but
what you really want first are the masks
start off smart with bow cobble and mask
and hit up a bow cobbling camp put on
the mask and you are in living it up
with pigs same goes for mob lands for
some great selfies
hmm the only thing to consider is that
if there's a different type of monster
nearby the whole scheme goes kaput in
order to get the lizalfos asked you'll
need to have completed two dungeons and
baby it's worth it for the mind games
give one of them a nice piece of meat
and watch them fight but my favorite is
to treat them both with their last meal
how's the meat guys good great now get
out for the Lydell mask you'll need
three dungeons completed it's very
useful for getting around these tricky
lion mane horses
however Lionel's aren't as dumb as the
other ones and they will eventually take
your impression of them personally I'm
sorry
other than the masks you got horse gear
that looks cool but doesn't really do
anything else but then there's the last
item on the list and you're probably
here just for it the Dark Link gear set
oh yeah in order to get this one though
you'll need to complete all four
dungeons and it'll set you back about
4000 Mon for the entire fit and you'll
want the entire fit because it's full
set bonus grants you a nighttime
speed-up buff what's more add on some
speed elixir and baby whoa you're
booking it now and there you have it
Hilton's monster shop if you're
interested in learning more about
breadth of the wild check out our
channel if you have any pointers
yourself send them our way in the chat
below because knowledge is power
[Music]